hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast intelligent NGSS a design
uncle mind focus a safe for NGS clinical
research in oncology and Judy O'Rourke
of lab roots and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
thermo fisher scientific for more
information please visit thermo
scientific calm before we get started a
poll question will appear on your screen
you may select an answer or close the
poll question by clicking on the X in
the right corner the question is what
level of experience do you have with
next-generation sequencing new to MGS
have no experience with next-generation
sequencing some experience with NGS have
used a service provider or run a few NGS
tests experienced have run multiple ngx
tests so we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen and screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Seth
status dr. status is the director of
oncology research and development in the
genetic applied in medical sciences
division of thermo fisher scientific
currently dr. status leads a team of
software engineers bioinformatics ists
and translational oncology scientists to
develop both research assays and
diagnostic tests on the Ion Torrent
next-generation sequencing platform
capillary electrophoresis sequencing
systems as well as qpcr and digital PCR
platforms dr. statist earned a PhD
biochemistry and completed a
postdoctoral fellowship at Harvard
Medical School his professional career
includes 15 years in the biopharma
industry spanning oncology drug
discovery through clinical development
and diagnostics I will now turn it over
to dr. status for his presentation well
hello everyone thanks for joining it's a
pleasure to be here I'm going to tell
you today about the work we are doing at
thermo fisher scientific office let me
close the poll question to advance
next-generation sequencing as a
companion diagnostic platform so first
at thermo Fisher we've created an
industry leader in serving science we
are a 17 billion dollar company with
nearly 50,000 employees around the world
and our scale and depth gives us deep
applications expertise and we use
expertise to help our customers solve
complex challenges whether they're in
life sciences healthcare environmental
or industrial markets okay but today
we're going to talk about precision
oncology let's first consider the scale
of the unmet need worldwide annual
estimates of cancer incidents include 14
million new cancer cases diagnosed in
2012 with 8.2 million deaths by 2030
according to the world health
organization the global cancer burden is
expected to exceed 21 million new cancer
cases with an thirteen million deaths
the impact of cancer on global health
care costs is staggering recently
estimated to be 895 billion dollars
annually greater than any other cause of
death including cardiovascular disease
in a recent report from ims institute of
healthcare informatics estimated the
annual spending on cancer medication
succeeded a hundred billion dollars for
the first time
14 clearly cancer has staggering costs
to our society in terms of lives
affected and also economic impact but
there is some good news on the horizon
in the form of personalized medicine
personalized medicine or precision
oncology is revolutionising the way
cancer is treated and how new cancer
medications are being discovered but
with these advances come challenges to
our current paradigm of one diagnostic
test from each new drug there are
discussions with pharmaceutical
companies around the world we have heard
a number of specific challenges being
faced today and oncology companion
diagnostic development is outlined in
this next slide biopsy samples for
testing and often come in limited sample
volumes there are multiple biomarkers to
test for one disease indication
sequential reflex testing is too slow
too cumbersome when multiple labs are
involved and often too expensive new
biomarkers are coming on the scene as
new targeted therapies show efficacy and
the fixed assay is needed for rapid
approval and related to this last point
this is a challenge we increasingly here
as we work with our pharmaceutical
partners their targeted therapies are
moving down the drug development pathway
very quickly and in some cases with a
breakthrough designation from the FDA
early responses are seen literally in
months and a lockdown companion
diagnostic that already has the
appropriate marker for the new therapy
analytically validated is needed to
support the approval process so I'm
going to tell you today how we seek to
leverage next-generation sequencing to
address some of these challenges
next-generation sequencing is having
amazing success in oncology today but
this has largely been in the laboratory
developed test setting as we seek to
partner with pharmaceutical companies to
advance their therapies we really need
an IV D companion diagnostic
kit that can be distributed globally to
serve the broader patient population
first let me tell you how we are
addressing these challenges we are
focusing first of all on somatic solid
tumor mutation profiling our goal is
straightforward to accurately detect all
relevant somatic alterations for solid
tumors with evidence linking those
alterations to targeted therapies this
slide describes division for the product
it begins with the solid tumor sample a
simple kited Ion Torrent sequencing
product that is capable of assessing
relative relevant alterations and a
sample report is provided that can
inform across a whole number of
important companion diagnostic decisions
now we didn't decide to do this on our
own we're building upon the success that
our customers were having with
next-generation sequencing in oncology
and its really been quite remarkable to
hear about the major successes that are
being had in the field with
next-generation sequencing we've had
several hundred tests launched on our
next-generation sequencing platform and
in 2014 literally hundreds of thousands
of cancer samples tested so the
technology is clearly a good fit for the
problem in the next slide outlined some
of the key attributes of our technology
platform when we think about
next-generation sequencing there are a
few players in the space that we are all
aware of I would just like to bring to
your attention that Ion Torrent benchtop
sequencing system has really established
itself in targeted sequencing in
oncology the attributes of the system
are well aligned with the needs of the
clinical setting low sample input fast
turnaround time and most especially for
the predefined variants that drives most
cancers and that are relevant for cancer
therapies
accuracy and reproducibility so we are
focusing our investments on advancing
this key work or sequencing platform in
the targeted sequencing companion
diagnostic space for oncology our
success in this oncology segment isn't
just based on the sequencer it's based
equally on our amplitude technology for
multiplex PCR live technology is now
part of thermo fisher scientific has a
rich long history in pcr and our teams
have done remarkable work in multiplex
pcr amplified enables multiplexing
literally thousands of PCR reactions for
simultaneous and relative uniform
amplification of DNA or RNA all with
minimal nucleic acid input and multiplex
PCR not only drives mutation detection
and key targets it also enables read
counting applications for copy number
alterations and gene fusion detection
and in fact the ability to input RNA
into this pcr workflow is extremely
powerful and has many applications not
only for gene fusion detection in the
RNA space but also for other gene
expression markers in cancer thus it is
these two technologies I annapolis seek
sequencing and I'm sorry I an amp
listing multiplex PCR and ion torrent
next-generation sequencing that form the
base of our technology platform and
there's a third element that is equally
important a rich cancer genomics and
annotation database that we termed the
Akamai knowledge base that we are
leveraging to inform the content of the
universal companion diagnostic and also
to provide annotations for the variants
that platform discovers bringing it all
together we are able to deliver an
integrated next-generation sequencing
solution that is focused on genetic
drivers of cancers and particularly
those with potential action ability
for my talk today I'm going to address
three challenges that we need to meet to
achieve our vision for the future the
first is content how do we anticipate
future companion diagnostic content
requirements we strive to build a
universal companion diagnostics test and
we could start with in markers we know
about today but we also need to look
forward to the content required for the
future so how do we do that second is
the assay how do we build an assay that
can measure a diverse set of genetic
alterations in cancer those that are
required for treatment decision making
third is ivd product development how do
we take what has traditionally been
research products leveraged local
laboratory settings and build a kidded
ivd product that can address these
challenges all right first let's review
content what genetic alterations do we
need to measure well we should certainly
start and include the approved existing
companion diagnostic single gene tests
that are on the market today but how do
we anticipate future companion
diagnostics biomarkers there are a
couple ways we can approach this we can
take a community approach where we bring
in key opinion leaders in pharmaceutical
companies or academic laboratories and
try to get a consensus this is often
difficult in the end we decided to be
mindful of this feedback but also to
pursue this from a data-driven approach
starting with genetic drivers of cancer
and also understanding their future
potential relevance based on the basis
of their inclusion in in clinical trials
today and it's drug targets for the
pharmaceutical industry this way we can
design a product that can serve us now
as well as in the years going forward it
start with genetic drivers of cancer if
we take all the amazing work that has
been done in cancer genomics can we
define the catalog of genetic drivers of
cancer using a comprehensive and
systematic evidence-based approach
so we surveyed thousands of exomes and
transcriptomes along with microarray
data for copy number alterations to
build a catalogue of what we believe are
the genetic drivers of cancer including
mutations copy number alterations and
gene fusions next we sought to determine
what set of those genetic drivers of
cancer were likely to be important
companion diagnostics markers so we
determined a set of genetic drivers of
cancer I'm sorry we determined 27
genetic drivers that were associated
with today's targeted therapies as well
as investigational therapies coming down
the pipeline for example we did a survey
and q1 this year we determined that
there were over 50 distinct genes with
clinical trial markers and over 70 gene
variant classes at Pharma trials were
using actively in real patients in over
300 open clinical trials here in the US
those trials involved over 70 different
single-agent targeted therapies and over
a hundred different combinations of
targeted therapies and chemotherapy so
based on this combination of genetic
variant and potential actionability
evidence we've built a catalogue what we
believe of the roving somatic
alterations in human cancer the next
slide illustrates that catalogue in the
content in the form of the event of a
variant map so this slide is only one
way to visualize this content what we
have in this plot our major cancer types
in rose and different variants in
columns some of those variants are
labeled with the size of the markers is
related to the prevalence with a cut-off
on the lower end of one percent in each
cancer type and the color of the marker
is related to the genetic alteration
type copy gain or copy laws hotspot
missense mutation or deleterious
mutation and here we mean frameshift in
dell or nonsense mutation
and gene fusions which you immediately
see in the major point of this slide
when you look at this data is that many
genetic markers are shared across
multiple cancer types for example b-raf
hotspot mutation prevalent in melanoma
and thyroid cancel it's also President
and colorectal cancer and now it's not
cell lung cancer as well as other kinds
of types the same goes for other hotspot
nonsense mutations beta-catenin is
prevalent in a number of cancer types k
rass mutation of course prevalent and
colorectal cancer and pancreatic
pancreatic cancer but many other cancer
types as well take three see a hotspot
mutations prevalent in breast cancer but
also many other cancer types as well and
the same goes for copy number drivers
cyclin d1 copy gain prevalent in many
cancer types / b2 copy gain prevalent in
many cancer types and also genes
subjective do terious mutations of
course p53 the most frequently mutated
gene and cancer all of these variants
are occurring in multiple cancer types
and if you've been studying cancer
genomic data for some time this is not
surprising but when you think about how
companion diagnostic markers are
developed in a cancer type specific
manner you appreciate how inefficient
that current strategy is so we have EGFR
and lung cancer b-raf in melanoma k rats
and colorectal cancer reality is these
markers exist at varying frequencies and
most other cancer types as do most other
genetic drivers and you really need only
one multivariate test to detect them all
that should be some kind of cost and
efficiency driver for the healthcare
system so here's another view of same
data we just narrowed it down to three
different major cancer types breast
colorectal non-small-cell lung making
the same point of course these are all
prevalent cancer types they all have
very different histologies ideologies
different you know treatment practices
and yet they share quite a number of
markers some of which are highlighted
here so therefore based on this data we
decided to design test for the relevant
markers and solid tumors as opposed to a
series of cancer type specific products
so today I'll describe two different
tests summarized here on this one yanka
mine focus assay which was designed to
detect key variants in 52 different
cancer genes and a broader on c'mon
comprehensive assay which was designed
to detect variants in a hundred and
forty three different cancer genes both
have the same core feature attribute
summarized below they both enabled
detection of relevant hotspots be they
based on single nucleotide variants or
insertions deletions copy number
alterations and gene fusions both
required just ten nanograms DNA or ten
nanograms RNA for a placebo for the
focus assay there is only one DNA
opposite pool and for the comprehensive
assay there are two different DNA
embassy pools and both have a
straightforward workflow with fast
turnaround time and both offer a single
workflow for DNA and RNA from the same
sample so first I'll describe the
alkaline focus assay which detects
variants in 52 key genes today this is a
research use only a say that sequence
its DNA and RNA from the same sample to
measure what we believe to be the
relevant somatic alterations in solid
tumors with potential actionability
events the panel content includes a
range of somatic alterations including
hotspots of both single nucleotide
variants and insertions deletions copy
number alterations and gene fusions the
markers include those currently
associated with drug labels and clinical
guidelines including not shown here
markers associated with clinical
evidence it's being published and open
and markers associated with open and
enrolling clinical trials or our part
of drug targets and are in active
development by pharmaceutical companies
the workflow was shown in the next slide
oh I'm sorry I skipped here I took out
that slide so the workflow you see that
I'm is done nope sorry okay let me just
speak quickly to the workflow the test
is designed to measure all of the
relevant alterations from six samples in
a single run together with the alkaline
knowledgebase reporter variants from
each sample can be aligned with curated
information including FDA labels
guidelines and clinical trial
information to develop a sample report
as authorized by the labs medical
director okay so in the next few slides
I'm going to show examples of how the
assay was used internally to detect
relevant variants and ffpe tumor samples
so first of all we'll look at mutations
and there's a clia-certified lab
associated with life technologies they
recently use the assay to characterize
mutations in a set of ffpe solid tumor
samples from different cancer types and
they then went back to the same samples
and used in orthogonal sequencing method
in this case Sanger capillary
electrophoresis sequencing to test
whether the mutations observed by the
focus assay the NGSS a could be
confirmed by the orthogonal test and
those are the results shown on this
slide so here in this table we have
samples listed in columns with the
cancer types of those samples listed on
the bottom and in rows we have variants
that were detected by both technologies
or by either technology so they first of
all we sequenced these blocks with the
NGSS a and then we went back to sequence
them on with Sanger and the dark the
green squares here indicate where
the results of the NGSS a and the Sanger
assay were an agreement the dart green
squares of those were mutation was
detected and in these cases these
hotspot mutations were observed both by
the NGSS a and by the Sanger sequencing
assay and in the light green squares no
mutation was detected for those variants
so the sequence was essentially
wild-type the yellow squares were those
samples that were sequenced by NGS but
we have not yet can analyze those anchor
sent those samples by singer and
importantly there are no red squares
here those would have been cases where
we would have had false positives or
false negatives so in this study
mutation allele frequencies range from
about 15 to about fifty percent in these
samples over all the small study
demonstrates that the alkaline focus
assay can accurately detect several
relevant variants from ffpe tumor tissue
and this is not surprising it's been
supported by all of the other data that
we've generated both on this assay in
our unrelated assays targeted sequencing
for predefined variants as a strength of
the Ion Torrent sequencing platform so
in addition to accurately detecting
hotspot variants we also had to develop
methods for copy number and gene fusion
detection because those alterations also
relevant genetic alterations that drive
cancer so in principle this should be
straightforward because relative changes
in copy number can be detected by
relative changes in recounts and fusion
events can be detected by targeted
sequencing across fusion breakpoints so
the next slide shows an example of copy
number alteration detection in
ffpe solid tumor samples in this
experiment we once again sequence two
large cohort of ffpe tumor samples
representing many different cancer types
and we sequence those by NGS and then we
also characterize some of those samples
by fluorescent in situ hybridization or
fish to detect copy changes in key
cancer genes and some of the key steps
for read normalization are outlined here
in the left panel and really copy number
detection by NGS is really based on your
ability to normalize recom distributions
and the right here we're summering data
for over 20 FFPE samples selected for
having high-level copy gain in at least
one gene and as you can see the NGS
estimate is in the y axis and the fish
copy number estimate is in the x axis
overall you see good concordance between
these two methods for estimating copy
numbers okay so in the next slide we
present an outline of the method used to
detect chain fusions in this method of
RNA is isolated from the sample and
converted a cdna fusion transcripts are
detected by designing specific amplicons
across fusion breakpoints and in the RNA
space these fusion breakpoints are
typically at although not always at exon
exon boundaries a library of reference
sequences is installed in the software
and alignment of sequence reads to the
reference sequences indicates a positive
detection as shown in these two examples
of the read alignments shown here in the
right panel so cancer researchers are
having good success with these assays to
detect relevant variants in cancer to
talk more about this let's go back to
the young c'mon comprehensive assay
which was designed to detect variants in
143 cancer genes so a much broader assay
with the increased number of hotspot
genes copy number drivers this assay
also includes 26 flow gene sequencing
assays for important tumor suppressor
genes and it also has a gene fusion
assay for important cancer-associated
drivers interestingly the number of
variants associated with drug labels and
guidelines is the same as that that we
showed previously with the focus assay
because we kept all of those variants
with with the greatest level of
potential action ability in the focus
assay okay the development of the assay
of this comprehensive assay along with
the results of a large cohort analysis
was recently published by our
collaborators Scott tomlin's and his
team at the University of Michigan so
first a slide on that workflow run a
simple workflow to assess both the DNA
and RNA associated variance from one
sample okay so here's just a face page
on the publication in this study the
researchers at the University of
Michigan used the online comprehensive
assay to sequence over 300 ffpe tumor
samples from three different cohorts two
cohorts were based on Bank samples from
lung cancer and prostate cancer in the
third cohort researchers obtained a
consecutive series of samples that had
been analyzed at the institution's
molecular diagnostics lab with validated
single gene tests they then analyzed a
series using the online comprehensive
assay and compare the results and those
that summarized in the next slide in
fact the NGSS a was able to perfectly
detect all three of the variants that
were previously detected with validated
single gene pcr-based tests in the
molecular
diagnostics lab so this molecular
characterized cohort contained 63
samples with known b-raf status
primarily from melanoma 22 samples with
known EGFR status primarily in rung
adenocarcinoma in 21 samples with known
krad status primarily in colorectal
adenocarcinoma so the one comprehensive
assay was useful to detect the relevant
variants in three different genes across
a range of solid tumor types and as you
might expect the on come on
comprehensive assay detected other
variants as well an example is shown on
this slide this slide shows two cases
where high level or the two gene
amplifications were unexpectedly
discovered in two different lung
carcinoma samples that were both and
here the copy number profiles that genes
are arranged in chromosomal order and
individual data points are actually the
amplicon from normalized amplicon
recounts and we're seeing relative gain
an Derby to read counts in these two
different samples and thus gain and Urbi
to copy number was if later validated by
immunohistochemistry shown the right
here so when combined with the Anka my
knowledge base reporter as shown in this
slide we were able to identify other
relevant alterations beyond routine
molecular testing and quickly understand
whether the additional variants that
were identified were associated with
approved drugs and guidelines or
clinical trials so in each pie chart
what we're showing here are the fraction
of variants associated with different
types of public evidence read variants
of those associated was approved drugs
so in this cohort we see a little bit
more than a quarter of the samples we
detected variants that were associated
with approved drugs and of course
in this molecular core appease her
samples analyzed that the molecular
diagnostics labs and had a number of
b-raf k lass egfr mutations orange and
yellow variants are those remaining
variants that were associated with
guidelines such as those from the
National Comprehensive Cancer Network in
the United States and the blue section
refers to those samples that had
additional variants that were associated
with the eligible eligibility criteria
of open and enrolling clinical trials so
this analysis demonstrates the value of
thinking beyond the current companion
diagnostic markers and instead taking a
broader approach to adds more value to
the test into the users of the test
using this assay researchers are
empowered to detect or to explore new or
rare cancer types katalogi new driver
mutations and rapidly understanding
their potential relevance there's an
example of this in a recent publication
that was featured on the cover of
molecular cancer research that described
med 12 is a frequently altered gene and
Floyd ease breast tumors here in in this
publication researchers were able to
assemble a cohort here in columns of
Floyd's breast tumor samples and they
sequence those samples using the Aquaman
comprehensive assay and this chart below
shows the variants they detected
including frequent hotspot alterations
in med 12 as well as other genetic
drivers with potential actionability
such as this copy number gain and the
igf-1r gene so this is a good example of
the power of the data-driven approach to
determine content we included med 12 on
the assay because he observed recurrent
hotspot mutations in many different
cancer types and of course we had no
indication that this was going to turn
out to be
a relevant and frequent marker in this
relatively rare cancer type fluid is
breast tumors alright so I'd like to
spend the last part of my time here
talking about how we plan to move this
technology down the ivd path and for
that first let's go back to the ankh
remind focus assay the alkaline focus
assay is to test we believe most of our
customers interested in testing relevant
cancer variants will want to use for the
advantages of an intelligent NGS content
design described here as well as
sensitive tumor analysis and also good
volume throughput on the PGM sequencing
and it's this assay that we intend to
take the ivd so if you go to the next
slide this is a high-level outline of
some of those plans first of all let's
talk about what we're doing in a
clinical trial space we're currently
collaborating with leaders in Japan of
the LC scrum and Gi screen trials these
are national trials national network of
hospitals obtaining samples for
sequencing using the Aquaman
comprehensive assay also collaborating
with the National Cancer Institute and
they're matched trial and all of these
trials the assay will be used to screen
thousands of samples to help match
patients too many different targeted
therapies and this forms important
experience for us as a basis from which
I you oh and I've ed submissions can be
developed in September last year we
announced a very important partnership
with Pfizer and GSK to advances
technology platform as an ipd kit our
initial focus will be on non-small cell
lung cancer as we all know each of our
and el corte de routine markers but
there are also other markers that are
associated with drugs that have
breakthrough status our first focus
therefore will be on lung cancer and
this product there will be two tiers of
Marcus we will have clinically validated
markers and on
so those markers that are still in the
investigational state that will be read
out is analytically validated markers
but with no clinical claims for egfr and
elk there will be straightforward to
demonstrate concordance to on market
tests and then we'll support our
partners in their breakthrough pathways
with b-raf and lost one tests so the
first product will have floor markers
for non-small cell lung cancer but that
will just be the beginning clinical
claims for additional markers and
expanded cancer types will be added
sequentially to move this product toward
their vision of a universal companion
diagnostic and this is the last slide a
summary slide in closing I hope I've
demonstrated to you that we are bringing
our technology to bear on this Universal
companion diagnostic challenge by
leading with a data-driven approach that
will serve the needs of today as well as
anticipate the needs of the future it
and our next steps are to take this
product through the regulatory pathway
and to commercialize the product
globally to support the use of the
amazing new targeted therapies that are
today revolutionising cancer treatment
so with that I'll clothes and we'll ask
for questions and thank everyone who
attended today for your attention
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can our first
question is are your customers using
these assays in the lab yes yes that's
right customers for this assay are are
those folks running NGS essays and
pathology labs often in hospital or
academic settings what is general time
to results from samples to answer most
of our customers are typically using one
of a three day turnaround time we're on
day one they extract a sample you see
the sample on day two they prepare
libraries and a three day sequence to
sample and of course every lab is
different i mentioned academic hospital
labs and we also have contract research
organization service labs some labs with
a that that work outside the strict
eight our schedule might have a
different turn around time what is the
Flex level that can be covered by your
targeted sequencing approach or how big
is the gene panel that can be covered
right great question so the alkaline
focus assay the Plex at the plex level
today is 8 I'm sorry six samples per PGM
318 chip and on that a say as I
described it covers 52 unique chain
targets in hotspot space we're covering
approximately 500 hotspot mutations
those are the most kind of relevant and
prevalent hotspot mutations in in all of
those targets 19 of the most relevant
and prevalent copy number drivers the
gene fusion panel is actually quite
expansive we're covering over 270
targeted breakpoints in the gene fusions
space and that's all in the online focus
assay which again is six samples PGM 318
shed the outcome on comprehensive assay
is a much broader assay although the
gene number is a 143 because we're
including full gene sequencing
applications for tumor suppressor genes
are actually covering quite a bit more
genomic space and throughput on the Plex
level on dad on the PGM is one sample
per PGM we have some customers that are
and we're starting to transition that sa
now to the proton system where we
anticipate a plex level of 8 to 12
samples for proton p1 shift how robust
is the cnv copying cutoff greater than 8
is matching normal required
great question so the data I showed for
the copy number alteration detection
shows relatively good concordance of
copy number estimates a level above 45
copy number all the way to very high and
our original on c'mon comprehensive
assay when we characterize performance
of that a say we set a threshold of
characterizing performance based on
samples with copy gain greater than
eight for example if we do that then we
get kind of what we what we you know
what we consider clinical grade
performance 95% sensitivity in
ninety-five percent specificity and you
know so that's one way to characterize
the overall performance of the assay
this with the Anka mine focus assay and
the results are shown in this
presentation will have similar
performance with with that kind of cut
off and perhaps even better we're still
assembling enough data to have a large
enough sample set to describe in that
fashion
what is the amplicon size for the focus
panel right the focus panel has I
believe it's about 269 amplicons for DNA
and as I said over 270 targeted
sequencing assays for gene fusions can
these assays be run on single cells
after amplifying the DNA to get the 10
ng DNA input interesting question we
have research you know in the peripheral
monitoring liquid biopsy space going on
right now that are investigating those
kinds of experiments i don't have the
results of that to present today but you
know certainly ten nanograms and you
know many of our customers out in the
field have have shown you know good
athletic performance with you know with
lower DNA inputs ten nanograms is kind
of the basic claim that we that we have
used over the years so i think the short
answer is that's work that's in
development to start with single cells
next one has a couple parts have you
looked into the possibility of using the
uncle mind panel for non-invasive
diagnostics for examples circulating
tumor DNA and would the workflow for the
diagnostic assay need to be used with
these kinds of samples yeah great
question yes so that that's as you can
imagine peripheral monitoring is
important application for NGS
and we're working hard on that right now
whether or not we ultimately recommend
you know the same workflow or something
different it is still under
consideration I would say but you know
we have a lot of optimism that is
targeted in NGS panels for oncology will
have an important role in peripheral
monitoring liquid biopsy is there any
change in chemistry to detecting long
insertions for example 30 BP long
insertion or even bigger yeah great
question whether or not there is a
change in chemistry or software in my
experience and it's it's also a
challenge of you know where a 30 base
pair insertion or deletion is situated
within the amplicon such that leads
coming off the sequencer can be can be
aligned around that insertion deletion
so I don't know that it's so much of a
chemistry as design and a software
challenge certainly the larger the in
dells get the more they kind of bumped
into amplicon edges and you know that
the amplitude approach has limitations
with extremely large insertions
deletions that approach the size of the
amplicons that being said there are very
few insertions and deletions that are
greater than 20 base pairs that are
really critical for oncology I'm not
saying there aren't any there may be a
few examples you know you might think of
the flip three itd is one of them but in
the solid tumor space almost all of the
prevalent insertions and deletions
are under 20 bases in length and the the
current system covers those the ones in
egfr the ones in kit the ones in earthy
too and the tech stoves with high
accuracy dislike technologies provide
sequencing services yeah so life
technologies has an affiliated CLIA lab
it's based here in California and they
they are they do provide sequencing
services most of their customers are
working for major pharmaceutical
companies or other other key key
customers in the segment it the intent
of that service it is not really to be a
contract research organization and to do
a lot of volume however the intent of
that service is to be a kind of a
showcase for our sequencing systems okay
we are out of time I would like to thank
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
November 26 2015 you'll receive an email
from lab roots alerting me when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to afford that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event see you next time
goodbye